hello and thank you for having me here
and I'm also really glad that from ELISA
muscles talk it seems that we're not
irrelevant yet in our jobs so that's
good because this talk is about people
now we're going to be talking about
creating an inclusive workplace culture
today
I'm Jana Chang and I'm an engineering
manager at Yelp in Hamburg and I also
lead the women in tech employee resource
group at Yelp in Germany to get started
let's start talking about this question
why do we want diversity you see
diversity is a pretty abstract concept
isn't it so I will want to rephrase this
question into something that's more
graspable why do we want people from
different cultures backgrounds and
genders to join our companies the reason
is simple as you can see there are a lot
of challenges that we're facing and
there are problems that hasn't been
resolved before so we don't just want
any solution we want the best solution
and the way to come up with it is to
source that solution from different
people because people from different
backgrounds approach problems in
different ways
that's why it's not a surprise that
gender diversity can improve team
decision-making and also innovation
capabilities that we emphasize so much
also in previous talks this is a quote
that I really like so I want to share
with all of you
diversity is being invited to a party
and inclusion is being asked to dance so
you can have people who are from diverse
backgrounds in your company and that's
like being invited to the party but can
they succeed can there have voices be
heard and can they bring their best
selves to work that's like being asked
to dance that's why we want to emphasize
that organizations benefit most from
gender diversity initiatives when they
have this supportive infrastructure and
that's what we're gonna be focusing on
today so now the question becomes how do
we create this culture where people from
all backgrounds can belong and succeed
in our companies so let's get started
here are a few ways that we've tried and
experimented at Yelp so I'm gonna a deep
dive into each and single one and see if
there is anyone that you like more and
try to implement first of all is a
top-down approach it's to make inclusion
a company-wide goal so if you want your
employees to care about inclusion we
have to show that the company cares as
well so how do we do that one of the
core values at Yelp is play well with
others I really like that because it
doesn't matter how well you can
contribute by yourself you work in a
team so the way we evaluate employees is
to see how well they can work with a
team and how well they can bring others
up and in fact we have incorporate that
into our engineering career levels in
terms of inclusion we're focusing in
three aspects well-being
community and championing we want to
know if people can help create an
engaging and supportive environment for
the team we want to see if people can
bring in diverse candidates in the
pipeline
because if you promote people who don't
have the skills to make everybody feel
welcome it actually prevents your
company's culture from being inclusive
imagine your leader you know this person
is the role model of your company and
they're not displaying inclusive
behaviors everybody's gonna follow suit
now what if we're not in the position
yet to you know come up with company's
strategies what can we do so there's
also this bottom-up approach which is to
start an employee resource group or to
help with it so this is something that
I've been doing and I'm gonna use the
example for women in tech because that's
something that is closer to my heart so
this to create this group our main
purpose is to increase women's sense of
belonging and also to level the playing
field talking about leveling the playing
field women in tech are under some
disadvantages right now if you think
about it
the gender pay gap right now in Germany
is 21.5 percent that's not a small
amount and at the same time for people
who are in tech we're 17% right now for
those people who are in tact we have
reports that people are a women in tech
are having less visibility in the
company or they're being pushed to do
less creative roles or some of them even
feel like their career are being stalled
and that's why we want to have these
women in tech groups so that we can
provide them on save space and also
offer opportunities to level that
playing field safe space because it's
difficult to fight against the system
when you're only one person as I
mentioned there are different challenges
being a woman in tech and I also want to
bring in the example of biases that
Marcel also mentioned remember the
example about Huskies and wolves
actually recently Amazon did a machine
learning algorithm that screens out
resumes to include that into their into
their hiring pipeline and accidentally
they screen out all the women in her
pipeline
and you know we're the snow in the case
no gender is that feature that there's a
strong correlation that if you're a men
that it's more likely that you're in the
field because we're only 17% but as you
can see biases can go a long way and
these are challenges that we need to
face on a day to day basis and that's
why with a safe space we can talk about
these issues support each other and try
to cope overcome these challenges at the
same time these groups can create
networking and professional
opportunities that can help increase
women in Tech's careers visibility so
we've organized a summit internal summit
where we invited women speakers to talk
about their work to try to increase
their visibility at the same time with
such a group right we can have a broader
network when we bring in more people so
it's not only the women in text network
because each and every one of them also
brings in the larger network of
themselves and hence we want to target
in that so that we can level the playing
field now after these two examples know
what if I'm not in the position to start
some strategies in the company and I
probably couldn't start an employee
resource group how can we help
mentorship it's a great thing we can
provide members of underrepresented
groups with role models and helping them
with their career with your own
experiences I have had a great
experience with mentorship on the left
here Virginia she's my mentor she helped
me out a lot when I first started
leading projects when I did my first
public speaking talk when I did
interviewing and right now when I'm
transitioning into the management role
she really helped help me out a lot and
the reason it's so valuable to me is
because I know that I'm not alone in
this there is someone who has gone
through that before now on the right
she's a guru and she's someone that I
mentored at Yelp she was an intern
coming in to yell and I'm glad to say
that she's now full-time with us and
she's doing really well on a team so I
hope she has always yep she has also
benefited some from the mentorship
experience
now this is something that we talk about
less but in my opinion is more important
sponsorship a mentorship what's the
difference
it's basically summed up in this comic
so I'll give you a second to look at it
and oftentimes people from
underrepresented background there over
mentored and under sponsored meaning
that there are a lot of people who give
them advice but who actually give them
the opportunity there are several
examples of how you can do it
for example telling their managers that
they have done an excellent job on
something lent them a book or giving
them the opportunity to work on
something challenging that's how you can
help now with a sponsor women are much
more likely to have their ideas endorsed
developed and implemented that's why I
would like all of you to help out in
this area and think about the people you
last suggested should work on projects
lend a book to or even refer to work at
your company how many of these people
are from an underrepresented background
you
if the answer is not too many then
that's something that we can work on
together another thing that is
interesting to talk about is fair
recognition
studies show that women's ideas are
taken less seriously compared to men
that's why we want to make sure that
recognition is fairly distributed this
actually doesn't only happen in tech it
also happens in politics there is
something called the amplification
strategy at the White House when a woman
made a key point other women will repeat
that key point and giving credit back to
its author so that's more visible so
that it's heard there is something that
we use at the app called Yelp love
because we believe that this also can be
solved by technology it's a simple app
that you can send love to your
colleagues meaning a small token of
appreciation if they did something for
you for example cover your on call on
called a cover take it for you that kind
of thing
there is also an occasion when we use
Yelp love that's when we launch a
project why is that because in this case
when the project lead sends out an email
with this love link we're carefully
counting who are the people that
actually contribute it in this project
so that we don't miss out anyone so
instead of someone who is most visible
in the company getting that credit we
want to make sure everybody who has
worked on the project are fairly
attributed
now last but not least is to speak up
against racist sexist homophobic
behaviors it's actually the most
difficult thing to do because the normal
reaction say if you hear a racist joke
is to shy away from it and you know walk
away or act awkward and I can understand
that's normal situation normal behavior
but imagine this situation when someone
said a sexist joke and I was there um so
think about in this situation what would
you do it's probably more awkward for me
to speak up and for you to speak up if
you're a guy because you can leverage
your privilege to help out and speak up
and point out things that are not fair
to others in fact there are trainings
that you can go to for example allied
trainings that is exactly to practice
that when you have an awkward situation
how do you handle that and we can try to
point out things that are not fair so
that we can create this inclusive
environment that we all want to close
off I want to mention that an inclusive
workplace culture is only achievable if
all people are on board so hopefully
after the talk there are small things
that you can try out there are little
things that you can experiment with and
let's make this industry a better place
for everybody to work at thank you
thank you very much Jenny and I think we
have maybe time for one question if
anyone
I do not see anyone so okay so I believe
this is a very important topic and I
want you contribute to this and I will
okay ladies awareness for this how do I
avoid seeming like the person who talks
you have like when I say yeah I think
that's a good point and there's a fine
line to walk right you don't want to
talk over somebody um I don't know if
there are people in your community who
are leaders from the underrepresented
group is there possible if you can like
work closely with them to figure out
something that you can do in your
community and to exert this influence
because if you can work with them you
can better understand their needs if
that's something that they want and you
can at the same time help out in this
for example like when I'm organizing
this summit for women in tech I also ask
for help from our allies because the
women in tech group is not just for
women in tech it's also for the allies
people who want to help out so in this
case I find it pretty helpful to have
other people who volunteer on this as
well so I believe you can do the same
perfect thank you very much perfect